les services techniques transformé en
atelier de découpe
muriel est agent d'accueil mais cette
semaine elle prépare des morceaux de
tissus ce pour fabriquer des sur vous
tous ces tissus sont en majorité des
draps qui proviennent des dons des
dolois puisque des bennes ont été
déposés dans les coins de la ville pour
récupérer tout ce que les gens pouvaient
nous donner les de loin ont fait du
rangement dans leurs armoires des
dizaines de draps et même une
montgolfière ont été développés les
couturiers viennent ensuite se servir
pour travailler chez eux et en moi
maintenant ces infirmiers donc ma
manière je participe et 7 participer
dans la mesure de mes possibilités
mais les blues en fait on a un certain
nombre de demandes importantes de toutes
les professions liées et bien aux
auxiliaires de vie aides soignants aux
ehpad de sur blues
parce qu'il ya une consommation qui est
très largement augmenté par rapport à
d'habitude et que l'on n'a pas assez de
fournitures nécessaires dans ces
établissements
d'habitude sylvie coût des vêtements
pour ses petits enfants
cette ancienne infirmière a décidé de
mettre à profit son confinement pour
aider le personnel soignant
elles passent environ une demi journée
par blues alors j'ai tout un patron sur
internet et avec du papier de
récupération
voilà j'ai tracé mon patron soir espace
les simples et puis la première que j'ai
réalisé que j'ai rallié hier
voilà qui ressemble un peu à quelque
chose quand même
la ville de dole continue de ramasser
des draps elle espère bien mobilisé une
cinquantaine de couturiers et
couturières aussi longtemps que
nécessaire